welcome back to Jake Berry and Kevin
McGuire is still with us so Jake Berry
you were fired after 50 days and the job
you've always wanted must have hurt well
even the best things must come to an end
Harry it was an amazing opportunity to
work really closely with Liz truss as
prime minister but I accept that you
know there's two real appointments that
are very close to the Prime Minister the
first is the party chairman the second
is the chief whip unfortunately come in
hand out with your prime minister I'd
hoped for a few more days but it was a
great privilege to have the opportunity
to do
less trust in those final final moments
in Downing Street some of those meetings
where everything was thrashed out what
was it like in there what was the mood
like I mean when did she really know
that it was over well look the the
former prime minister was always very
cheaper
um and she was a fighter not a quitter
as I think she said to Parliament
I think there came a point where she
realized that the the all the newspapers
including ones that are traditionally
supportive of the conservative party had
really made their mind up about her
colleagues had made their mind up about
her and there was no real way of
fighting back and that was compounded uh
that the straw that broke the back of
the very heavily burdened camel was the
chaos that we saw in the division Lobby
over the the fracking vote and it sort
of that felt like the point of no return
it was extraordinary but mistakes have
been made long before then even the very
earliest days of her Premiership when
did you realize it was going south
well I you know I I I kept fighting I
mean there was always the eternal
optimist and I thought you know I think
the danger is with having changed prime
minister now is that I made this point
to colleagues in advance of the changes
in dangerous that the real questions out
there now in the country about whether
we should have a general election that
would be frankly a catastrophe for the
conservative party and I do support
Rishi sunax call to unite behind him and
focus on the national interest but I
think those questions about when that
election will come will get louder and
louder particularly from opposition
parties I wanted to come to that because
you were responsible for the party's
membership there was a feeling over the
last couple of days that the members
have been ignored and they're the people
who ultimately you're going to ask to
vote for you I mean do you think that
relationship between the Westminster
Party and the conservative membership is
you know can you put it back together or
is it broken now well look we can always
put it back together but I think it has
been severely damaged I was a big
advocate of having a members vote
um I didn't really actually like when we
saw the 1922 committee a sort of all
male panel a bit like the sort of
Chinese politburo grinning saying there
is one candidate and acclaiming that
candidate I would have really liked to
have seen a competition that's not what
my colleagues wanted and the
conservative party was ready in short
order to do an online vote which would
have delayed the process of the
selection of the new prime minister only
by 48 hours I'm sure the members feel
quite angry about that I'm just an
ordinary member of the conservative
party as well as being an MP I would
have liked to have had my say because I
didn't even get a vote in that election
because I was sort of you know in charge
of the election so I you know I think
it's a Pity one person that could have
avoided the talk of the general election
is the man with the Mandate Boris
Johnson you backed him in 2009 19. did
you want him to come back this time well
I backed him in 2016 and 2019 I'm a
long-term friend and Backer of Boris
Johnson I accept actually it probably
wasn't the right time for him to come
back I presume he will have thoughts
about coming back at some future days
but he tried very hard and he led a lot
of people up the hill and you know sort
of the plug out at the last minute while
people still saying he should come back
on television do you think
Boris Johnson has stood in three
leadership elections and withdrawn from
two of them and it's surely done now
though isn't it well I don't know you
know I think people have got Paul
betting against the bounce back he's the
proverbial rubber ball keeps bouncing
back would you vote for him again
um well okay I have to wait and see
some of the problems that that were
there for Boris Johnson and for Liz
truss are still there for Rishi sunak
and even though your party Feels buoyed
by prime minister's questions today the
reality is it's going to be you know a
difficult couple of months you mentioned
a general election there do you think
it's possible for the party to solve
those issues without one now yeah I do I
mean I thought actually pmqs was the
best sort of first outing at pmqs I've
seen in the whatever it is now five
Prime Ministers that I've seen on their
first outing in that role I thought it
was fantastic look whether we like it or
not we don't live in a presidential
country parties get elected parties then
choose their leader and they become
Prime Minister I thought the interesting
thing is that no prime minister since
1974 has come in and out of office for
our general election that's a very long
time and it shows that both labor and
conservatives do reserve the right to
change their leader halfway through in
Parliament and just give us an Insight
before we let you go at least for this
segment what was it like to be sacked
how did that go down yeah a lot I
understand I've known Rishi sunaka a
long time I went in and he gave me a
sort of speech about you know all the
things I'd done which he thought were
great which was nice to hear but then
ultimately you know there just aren't
enough seats around the table for
everyone
I I'd gone out to bat for the Prime
Minister both during the the former
prime minister both during the
leadership election and in her last days
and down the streets and nurses I say it
was a personal appointment I was very
personally loyal to her I didn't expect
to continue in my role but I do wish
Rishi and his new Team all the best and
I really hope they can unite and win
that general election so Jake Berry you
served in the government was well Brave
and is she the right person to fix this
well look let's look at the facts we are
currently spending seven million pounds
a day
been in a year housing people in United
well just think of those seats up and
down the country who'd happily take two
days worth of that money to really
Revitalize the high streets it's not
working and I think we do need a new
approach the first thing I would like to
see us commit to is if you cross the
channel illegally you should be sent
back to France you shouldn't be given us
all in this country I would like you
know forget planes taking off and going
to Rwanda I'd like to see ferries going
from Dover to Calais or yeah that way
around that's fine David's Calais with
people who've come to this country
illegally we have a proud history of
welcoming people to this country but
there are many legal routes and if
people cross illegally they should be
I'm Sue Ellen brethman though you were
there in the government and in the
bunker at the end when she was fired was
it right that she came back
but six days is a long time in politics
it's for the new prime minister and he
must be free to point to everyone so
look what I would say is
from my own knowledge there were
multiple breaches of the ministerial
code in fact multiple multiple beaches
of the ministerial code it was sent from
a private email address to another
Member of Parliament she then sought to
copy of that individual's wife and
accidentally sent it to a staffer in
Parliament to me that seems a really
serious breach especially when it was
documents relating to cyber security as
I believe that seems a really serious
breach the cabinet secretary had his day
at the time I doubt he's changed his
mind in the last six days but that's a
that's a matter for the new promise and
did she hold her hands up to it in that
meeting did she admit it well I wasn't I
wasn't in the meeting because I
understand it the evidence was put to
her and she accepted the evidence rather
than the other way around Jake Barry
Kevin McGuire thank you very much